[Music]
greetings developers and welcome to
serverless migration station where we
show you one serverless compute
modernization technique i'm wesley john
of google joined by martin and our
friend porter here to take you from
point a to point b
today's migration represents a product
crossover showing you how to
containerize your app engine apps to run
on cloud run our serverless container
hosting service wow that sounds pretty
complicated
containerizing your app i'm just a
simple web developer how much do i have
to learn about containers great question
martin developers out there already
familiar with docker don't have much to
learn since they've already been
creating and deploying containers using
docker to create a container for cloud
run is pretty much the same as anywhere
else
on the other hand if you're completely
new to containers don't worry we'll take
care of you too in this module 4 video
we'll focus on docker but in module 5
we'll show you how to container ride
your apps without having to know
anything about docker or containers
that's great to know that google cloud
is for docker veterans and container
newbies uh so for folks like me who are
new what's the elevator pitch for
containers anyway well glad you asked
martin with the seed planted years ago
containers came to the forefront when
virtualization became a thing around the
beginning of the millennium and were
accelerated specifically for application
packaging about a decade later by docker
of course programming has been around
for longer than that and some of us have
been writing code for ages without
containers while optional containerizing
gives developers the most freedom and
flexibility in bundling their app
they're easily reproducible and you can
use or reuse them anywhere you want
making them extremely portable too
come on those are just marketing
buzzwords wes what do they mean for
developers like us well you ask for the
elevator pitch this is gonna take a
little longer than one elevator right
now
well containers give you the flexibility
to bundle whatever your apps need
freeing you from traditional serverless
restrictions like you have to use this
language or you can't model that library
because it's in c plus
furthermore a container is reproducible
you can figure how the container is
built and if you use the same
instructions you could create an
identical container this is valuable not
just for testing but also for verifying
your app works with which versions of
your dependencies no more deploying apps
and hoping the production libraries are
compatible
okay so my users are based all over the
world so i want to deploy the same
service everywhere
also if i had a bad build i want to roll
back to the previous working version
so the same container image can be
deployed anywhere and if there's a
problem i can roll back to a previous
container image oh for sure i mean i
know we're talking serverless here but
realize containers are ultra portable as
that same container image can be
deployed to you your compute engine vms
kubernetes in the cloud your vms on-prem
hybrid or even multi-cloud think of
containers like a shopping bag to bundle
your code and its dependencies imagine
carrying everything you bought at the
market separately to your car on the
subway
that shopping back analogy makes a lot
of sense to me i'm sold in containers
uh but do i have to containerize my app
engine apps
i'm kind of used to app engine style of
development where i improve my code you
know i deploy to staging and then
eventually to production
yeah as i mentioned earlier i've been
writing apps for years without
containers so if you're comfortable
there that's fine but realize that
industry has moved towards containers in
a big way so they're there for you when
you're ready i think you'll like our
next video though because we'll show you
how to containerize apps without knowing
much about containers so stay tuned for
that for now google has expressed
long-term support for app engine but
much of our effort is going to cloud run
because containers are a de facto
standard now
well i'm ready now
but before that i do have some python 2
legacy apps
i know it's been deprecated by the
community and all that but so i'm
concerned uh do you have any options for
me yeah you're not alone martin many
python 2 developers share those concerns
however that long term support page
links to another page where google has
committed to supporting the app engine
2.7 runtime letting you move when ready
and did you already forget that cloud
run supports any language any library
any binary containerizing is one way to
keep your python 2 app alive forever
well if you put it that way worth i'm
going to containerize two app engine
apps the python 2 cloud ndb app from
module 2
and the python 3 cloud data store app
from module 3.
sure martin porter has lots of energy
today so we'll do both which is why
there are python 2 and 3 folders for
module 4 when we're done
check out the module 2 or 3 videos and
repo folders to re-familiarize
yourselves with each the python2 cloud
ndb app is in the module 2a folder while
the python 3 cloud datastore app is in
the module 3b folder let's pause for a
moment for you to catch up and grab your
starting code base
got it great now let's go containerize
them
as with most migrations it's always a
good idea to check that you're starting
from a working app whether the module 2
cloud ndb python 2 app or the module 3
cloud datastore python 3 app please
redeploy yours or ours as suggested
moments ago with gcloud app deploy and
verify it works where you get the same
output as from previous modules
changing products from app engine to
cloud run requires configuration changes
so we suggest you make a full copy of
your working app folder
now it's safe to make the necessary
changes containerizing that app
first delete the app.yaml file that is
not used in cloud run
if migrating the python 2 cloud adb app
also delete app engine config.py and the
lib folder
more app engine artifacts are used in
cloud run
next let's tackle requirements.txt
app engine and cloud functions are
source based and start your app with a
production ready server since cloud run
is a bit more diy you need to roll your
own python app engine uses the g-unicorn
production ready server if you don't
specify your own so let's use that one
for cloud run by adding it to
requirements.txt
i like to put my packages in lowest to
highest level order which is why i
listed it first for the python 2 app
you'll have g unicorn flask and cloud
ndb whereas for the python3 app it'll be
g unicorn flask and cloud datastore
version numbers are a good practice
however they change a lot and differ
between python 2 and 3 so that's why
we're not showing any here they're in
the repo files though
when using docker the main config file
you need is a docker file so create that
with the content you see on screen or
download it from the repo
if you're new to docker files you need
to start with a base container in this
case a minimal python 2 or 3 image from
here create and cd into your working
directory arbitrarily called app with
the workdure command
now copy all the source code into app
and run pip install so your application
can use those packages listed in
requirements.txt
finally entry point tells the system to
start gene unicorn to serve your app
check the dockerfile best practices page
for more info another good practice is
to add a docker ignore file while it is
optional it helps keep unnecessary files
from being added to your container it's
less important for our sample apps since
they're so small that it can have a
positive impact on your apps controlling
container size and preventing accidental
exposure of secrets like api keys or
oauth credentials this isn't python
related so you can use the same docker
ignore from both python 2 and 3 apps
since we're migrating identical apps to
cloud run there are no other changes
other than configuration updates that
means we can just deploy it now we're
done
instead of gcloud app deploy for app
engine the command now is gcloud run
deploy service name dash dash source dot
to deploy the app from the source code
in the current directory
instead of deploying an app with cloud
run you deploy a service so you have to
come up with a service name hopefully
more exciting than app engine's default
cloud run also has more options so
you're going to be asked what region to
deploy to and whether you're allowing
open internet traffic
lastly cloud run is available in other
form factors but the one closest to app
engine is fully managed
if you don't want to get asked all of
these every single time provide them on
the command line as options like this
one here that i'm using for our app
calling the service visit me
and like your app engine app your server
should be available in globally in under
a minute at a unique url you can point
to with a custom domain
hit it with your browser confirm you now
have a running cloud run app cool so
what do you think martin
wow wes that was way easier than i
thought it was going to be i was a bit
apprehensive about learning these
containers but it doesn't look that bad
but
watching you do it is too easy where can
i try these migrations myself of course
martin all modules have a corresponding
code lab linked in the repo and below we
walk you through this migration step by
step if things don't go well migrating
the python 2 cloud ndb app grab it again
from the module 2a start folder the same
is true with the python 3 cloud
datastore app reset to its module 3b
folder if you need to
you can compare your solution with ours
in the modules 4a or 4b finish folders
another link we're leaving for you is to
the gcloud run deploy docs in case
you're curious how it works and what
else you can do with it
great i'm looking forward to doing those
by hand but i am still concerned about
that docker file our sample app is quite
simple so there wasn't any trouble but
you know out in the real world yeah i
know you have many more dependencies and
it's easier to create sub-optimal or
overly complex docker files these can
lead to slowing down the build
deployment and execution of your
containerized app that's why you should
check out module 5 where you don't have
to worry about docker files anymore
we'll add a link to the video once it's
ready but for now you can already do its
code lab oh i look forward to seeing
that
by the way my devops co-workers told me
they preferred if my app can be
integrated in our cscd pipeline
can cloudrun do that with
oh yeah on the cd side one cool feature
of cloud run is that you can deploy
direct from a code push
this is configured in the cloud console
if your code is in a repo system like
github or bitbucket when a commit takes
place it triggers cloud build to build
and register your container then deploys
it to cloud run if you slip in a service
like github actions that build and test
your code before sending it to cloud run
you'll have that ci cd environment you
asked for see the link to our community
tutorial to learn more about how to do
that
okay great thanks wes aside from
containerizing my app engine apps for
cloudron uh what are some other
migrations i should consider
well aside from the next video on
containerizing your app without docker
if you're on cloud ndb and have other
code using the cloud datastore client
library consider consolidating to one
client library that's covered in module
3. if you're excited about all those
firebase features in cloud firestore and
willing to move your app to a new
project check out modules 6 and 10.
if your app uses app engine task queues
migrate to cloud tasks and that's
covered in modules 7 8 and 9.
finally if your app engine app is pretty
small or does only one thing consider
migrating to cloud functions that'll be
found in module 11. but note you have to
port your code from python 2 to 3 first
as cloud functions only supports python
3. and thank all of you for staying with
us on all of these migration journeys
please join us for the module 5
migration station not only to learn more
about containers but it's all of the
stuff that we didn't get a chance to
cover today this is wesley stern from
google cloud on behalf of martin and
porter we hope to see you at the next
migration station or on another
serverless expedition soon
[Music]